diese gentechnisch geschaffene pflanze
steht im zentrum einer kontroverse eine
kontroverse über unseren umgang mit
einer der mächtigsten technologien geht
der mensch je entwickelt hat eine
technologie die die gesellschaft spaltet
die akteure ein heute emeritierter
professor der eth der mit seinem golden
rice kinder in der ganzen welt retten
will
ein schweizer agrochemiekonzern der den
wunder reis erst kommerzialisieren will
und dann doch nicht und ein land wo
getestet wird was anderswo nicht erlaubt
wäre
[Musik]
forscher die gene an nutzpflanzen
manipulieren fordern von der politik
mehr freiheit die freiheit zu forschen
sie fühlen sich durch das gentech
moratorium seit jahren zu unrecht
behindert doch das misstrauen der
öffentlichkeit gegenüber den gen
manipulatoren ist seit jahren groß
[Musik]
das künstliche verändert der genetik der
pflanzen und tieren schafft ängste auch
weil forscher sich nur ungern in die
karten schauen lassen was sie
tatsächlich tun
in diesem spannungsfeld kreiert in den
gewächshäusern der eth zürich der
pflanzen wissenschafts professor ingo
potrykus an den gegen tec reis der
provitamin a enthält
[Musik]
ein raise der unterernährten menschen
zugute kommen soll und nicht der profit
gier der agroindustrie ich hoffe dass
die mütter von den familien in den
medien a mangel ein problem ist
begriffen haben dass es gut sein wird
diesen reis zu essen wir erwarten dass
dieser goldene reis ende dieses jahres
in den philippinen endlich zum bauern
kommt es ist ein vorzeigeprojekt der
gentech industrie
das ist ein trojanisches pferd der
goldene reis segen oder fluch
die spurensuche führt uns auf die
philippinen an land mit 90 millionen
reißer ein land bereist nicht nur
grundnahrungsmittel ist sondern teil der
kultur in diesem land soll die leute auf
einen neuen goldgelben reis umstellen
und ihre gewohnheiten über bord werfen
wir sind auf die philippinen gereist
weil wir erfahren wollen wie diese idee
umgesetzt wird
die behörden sollen laut unserer
informationen noch dieses jahr über eine
zulassung entscheiden
beim internationalen
reisforschungsinstitut irri laufen die
vorbereitungen auf hochtouren
mit den reis auf den markt bringen
wir beginnen unsere suche in der
hauptstadt manila
eine zwölf millionen metropole
wollen die menschen auf den philippinen
solchen reis sind alle risiken abgeklärt
oder haben die leute angst vor heute
noch unbekannten nebenwirkungen
wenn in diesen regalen schon bald das
wichtigste grundnahrungsmittel
gentechnologisch verändert angeboten
wird
wir sitzen im hotel fest seit wochen
sind wir im kontakt mit den behörden
jetzt wo wir da sind wollen sie uns
nicht empfangen
warum nicht könnten wir unangenehme
fragen stellen
auch der kontakt mit dem ihre bricht ab
noch in der schweiz hatten wir abgemacht
die nächste goldene reis ende zu filmen
doch einen monat vorher kommt eine
absage
deshalb sagt dass ihre uns nicht wir
wundern uns zum ersten mal der vater
dieses wunder rises ingo potrykus wohnt
und arbeitet seit jahren in der schweiz
er ist beseelt von der idee die
unpopuläre gentechnik dafür einzusetzen
menschen zu helfen
seit dem ersten jahr meine arbeit war
mein wunsch meine arbeit so zu
organisieren dass die nutznießer die
armen sind
ich bin kein wissenschaftler
ich bin ein ingenieur ich möchte
praktische probleme lösen
ich benutze wissenschaft als mittel um
ein praktisches volle hin zu lösen und
sie steht im zentrum seines schaffens
unter oder mangelernährte kinder und
schwangere frauen
akuter vitamin a mangel führt vor allem
bei ihnen zu blindheit oder gar tot
ww who schätzt dass weltweit 200
millionen kinder an vitamin a mangel
ingo potrykus konzentrierte seiner
arbeitszeit den achtziger jahren nur
noch ein freies auf das
grundnahrungsmittel damen erforschte 13
jahre ohne sichtbaren erfolg schloss
sich mit peter beyer einem zellbiologen
aus freiburg zusammen
sie schafften schließlich das
unvorstellbare im februar 1999 ruft mich
der peter war abends in meinem labor
anderswo schon lange dunkel
ich war noch da und er ruft mich an sagt
machen wir da einen computer auf ich
finde ein bild das war der spaß machen
und wir waren natürlich elektrisiert
nach so langer zeit nicht nur weiße
sondern auf einmal ein paar gelbe
reiskörner zu sehen denn dort haben wir
gesehen wir haben es tatsächlich
geschafft
für diese erfindung wurden ingo potrykus
und sein kollege von der ganzen welt
presse gefeiert
auch die wissenschaft ehrte die beiden
trikots wurde sogar für den nobelpreis
vorgeschlagen
auch beim papst erhielt er eine audienz
und durfte für sein anliegen werden
doch damit bei der golden rice ingenieur
noch lange nicht am ziel
[Musik]
auf den philippinen machen wir uns auf
die suche nach den menschen die an
vitamin a mangel leiden paters eine
siedlung am rande der metropole von
manila
ihr leben zehntausende von dem was sie
auf den müll finden
was sie im abfall an verwertbarem finden
versuchen sie für ein paar pesos zu
verkaufen doch für eine gesunde
ernährung reicht das kaum
wir begleiten die gemeinde erst denn el
baradei eisen auf ihrem rundgang durch
die siedlung
das leben hier sehr hart der ziel zu uns
viele hätten nur eine maximal zwei
mahlzeiten pro tag
die ärztin untersucht die kinder in
regelmäßigen abständen auf alle
möglichen probleme häufig seien atemwegs
erkrankungen und infektionen auch
verdauungsbeschwerden
und wie sieht es mit dem vitamin a
mangel aus ich bin seit drei jahren
ärztin bayer dass ich habe hier noch
keinen fall gesehen von vitamin a mangel
der grund dafür ist wahrscheinlich dass
regelmäßig vitamin a an kinder abgegeben
wird
es ist ein reguläres programm des
gesundheitsdepartements in solchen
gesundheitszentren gibt der staat
vitamin a abt kinder im alter von
halbjährig bis fünf bekommen zwei gaben
pro jahr gratis
das programm ist ein erfolg laut einer
nationalen statistik waren vor zehn
jahren 40 prozent der bevölkerung
vitamin a unterversorgt vor fünf jahren
nur noch 15 prozent
wie viele es heute sind ist nicht
bekannt
[Musik]
billiger für die regierung wäre der
provitamin a reist davon sind die
erfinder des reises überzeugt doch
zuerst muss der goldene reis den sprung
aus dem labor auf die felder schaffen
die forscher gehen auf die suche nach
geld und power
beides finden sie beim weltweit größten
agrochemiekonzern syngenta in basel
im winter nicht auf ein angebot von uns
eingegangen unser angebot war folgendes
wir übertragen die rechte an unsere
erfindung für kommerzielle nutzung an
die firma bereit ist im gegenzug unser
humanitäres projektion unterstützen die
heikle frage dabei wo liegt die grenze
zwischen kommerzieller und humanitärer
nutzung unser ziel war alle armen bauern
kostenlos teilnehmen zu lassen und sind
das interesse war natürlich dass
möglichst eng zu definieren
denn sie wollten haben möglicherweise
ein geschäft machen wir haben uns dann
auf eine definition geeinigt wenn ein
reisbauer nicht mehr als 10.000 dollar
pro jahr
mit diesem golden rice profit macht dann
wird das noch alles zum militär
betrachtet syngenta verfeinert den
gentechnischen eingriff von ursprünglich
neun genen hat es im goldenen reis von
heute nur noch zwei artfremde gene ein
meist gehen und ein gehen aus einem
bakterien
[Musik]
ingo potrykus gründet das golden rice
humanitären bord dieses gremium will
goldenen reis zum welterfolg machen
geschäftsführender sekretär wird er in
die box ein ehemaliger syngenta man
nennt die geldgeber des golden rice
heute wird das golden rice projekt auf
den philippinen und in bangladesch von
der gates foundation finanziert und das
seit ein paar jahren ein kleiner teil
kommt von der rockefeller foundation ein
weiterer von us- die in asien
auch wenn buffett der vater von bill
gates sind dabei ich glaube sie alle
wollen mithelfen gesundheitsprobleme zu
lösen die armut zu bekämpfen und die
lebenserwartung und lebensqualität
dieser menschen zu verbessern
illustre namen potente geldgeber als
gutmenschen driburg lässt durchblicken
dass das geld der schwerreichen nicht
nur segen sondern auch gefahren mit sich
bringt aber ohne wären wir nirgends wir
sind sehr froh darum wann immer du geld
von einer organisation akzeptierst will
sich die organisation auch einbringen im
management und mitreden
das ist verständlich und kann auch nicht
verweigert werden
die grid foundation will den gelben vun
de reis als erstes auf den philippinen
in umlauf bringen
wir sind auf dem weg dorthin wo die
ernte des wichtigsten aber gehen
veränderten grundnahrungsmittels ansteht
das durch die bisher noch kein
fernsehteam filmen auch nach dem rückzug
der einladung wollen wir es versuchen
wir treffen uns mit örtlichen leuten von
greenpeace sie beobachten die
aktivitäten rund um golden rice kritisch
deshalb kennen sie die standorte der
golden reisfelder genau ein spähtrupp
der unerkannt bleiben will hat bereits
das gelände erkundet wir gehen über den
haupteingang auf das gelände
und dann dieser straße entlang bis ans
ende
da hinten beim pflanze aus ist das
vermutete golden rice feld
ist das eingezäunt ja es ist eingezäunt
und abgesperrt schafft es greenpeace uns
dorthin zu bringen
warum wollen sie uns das zeigen damit
die öffentlichkeit etwas erfährt die
debatte über die sicherheit und den
golden rice müsste viel öffentlicher
geführt werden das testfeld gilt auf dem
gelände von viel reis dem nationalen
reisforschungsinstitut viel reis und
ihre arbeiten beim golden rice eng
zusammen
am haupteingang kommen wir nicht weiter
schreiben sie hier ihren namen und den
offiziellen grund ihres besuches an ein
einfaches durchkommen ist nicht mehr zu
denken
eine angestellte für die uns zu ihrem
chef
[Musik]
wir fragen ihn ob wir die gold weiß
ernte für das schweizer fernsehen filmen
dürfen
bitte nicht viel
keine kamera keine auskunft
wie bei einem gut gehüteten geheimnis
sehen dürfen wir den golden rice nur auf
dem werbeplakat
doch sollte dieser wunde reis nicht
schon dieses jahr auf den markt kommen
wiederum wundern wir uns wir versuchen
von der hinteren seite des kalenders
einen blick auf das testfeld zu
erhaschen
da kann man das testfeld sehen
[Musik]
näher kommen wir nicht mehr heran das
testfeld ist eingezäunt
genaueres ist aber nicht zu erkennen
weshalb soll die öffentlichkeit nicht
erfahren was dort abläuft ist bei der
golden rice wird als musterbeispiel
gebraucht um akzeptanz für alle anderen
genentech organismen zu schaffen ohne
fragen ohne genaue überprüfung ohne dass
die öffentlichkeit davon kenntnis hat
man kann ja nicht mal die felder sehen
aber wir sind es die das risiko tragen
wenn der goldene reis rauskommt also
müssen wir doch auf die risiken kennen
um zu beurteilen ob er das risiko tragen
können das sollte die
entscheidungsgrundlage sein ob man den
reis bewilligt oder nicht
opposition wächst im goldenen reis auf
den philippinen auch auf
parlamentarischer ebene in manila
treffen wir raphael mariano er ist
abgeordneter im philippinischen
repräsentantenhaus vertreter der gentech
kritischen kreise er gibt sich
kämpferisch
es sind jetzt bereits mehr als fünf
provinzen die feldversuche und eine
kommerzialisierung von gentech
organismen von gentech produkten
inklusive golden rice auf ihrem boden
verboten haben
und es werden immer mehr
wir werden nicht erlauben dass golden
rice und sein markt überflutet und dass
wir von einigen wenigen transnationalen
firmen giganten wie syngenta
kontrolliert werden
aber der goldpreis soll gratis sein
gratis
ich glaube nicht dass der für immer
gratis sein
ihr oberstes motives profit nicht
humanität nicht soziale gerechtigkeit
und gleichheit sondern soziale
ungleichheit das projekt hat eine große
position ohne zweifel
können sie das verstehen nein denn
dieser reise ist wie normale reis
außerdem beta carotin oder provitamin a
warum sollte man jemanden der provitamin
a zum überleben oder sehen braucht das
nicht geben
aus ideologischen gründen weil man die
globalisierung nicht mag oder den
kapitalismus weil man eine romantische
verklärung zu kleinbauern hat ge und sei
einmal ein kleinbauer in einem
entwicklungsland versuche für ein jahr
arm zu sein und schaudern was du denkst
wir gehen und erkundigen uns auf einem
typischen markt was die leute von der
straße vom wunder reis halten
wie so oft bei einem neuen produkt stößt
es am anfang auf eine gewisse skepsis
dennoch interessiert uns die spontane
reaktion der leute wenn sie statt wie
üblich weißen oder roten plötzlich
gelben reis hin
wir haben eine kleine dose mit golden
rice mitgebracht und zeigen sie käufern
und verkäufern
was denken sie über diesen reis
[Applaus]
preis her
der ist anders als unser reichen ich
weiß nicht ich habe diesen preis noch
nie probiert
[Musik]
würden sie ihn verkaufen
ich glaube nicht ich mag diesen reißt
aber ich müsste ihn probieren bevor ich
in kauf
der ist nicht gut weil er gelb ist wie
sehr alte rais den leuten würde er nicht
gefallen
[Musik]
sehr eng mit dem philippinischen volk
verbunden ist die katholische kirche 90
prozent der bevölkerung gehören ihr an
sie ist ein gewichtiger machtfaktor im
land
den gesprächen erfahren wir dass die
katholische kirche sich gegen
gentechnologie golden rice ausspricht
rudis kompendium da der vatikan sagt
hier im kompendium die armut mit
gentechnologie lösen zu wollen sei eine
irrige these wir in der kirche sind klar
gegen gentechnologie und auch gegen
golden rice
wir glauben dass diese gentech produkte
ein risiko für die gesundheit sind
wir sollten nicht die gesundheit der
leute opfern für den kurzfristigen
gewinn von firmen viel misstrauen und
widerstand gegenüber dem wunder reis aus
der schweiz
man bekommt das gefühl sie wollten
diesen leuten helfen aber die wollen
eigentlich ihre hilfe gar nicht
ja völlig richtig überrascht sie das
also sollten sie eigentlich genügend
erfahrung haben wie unpopulär
transgene pflanzen sind diese golden
rice ist ein für professionelle
gentechnik gegen ein gefährliches
gewachsen
es zeigt auf einmal dass die technologie
nicht nur zum nutzen von monsanto
eingesetzt wird sondern zum nutzen der
armen für öffentliches gut zur
verbesserung der gesundheit das niemand
ein profit davon hat ich habe in meinem
ganzen leben nie einen cent dafür
bekommen für unsere arbeit das ganze
monetäre bord hat nur die eigene zeit
investiert aber nie in einen
finanziellen nutzen davon gehabt das
heißt also die ganzen argumente die die
gentechnik entführen die gelten auf
einmal nicht
und dass wir bekämpfen sie den golden
rice mit allen mitteln mit allen tricks
china janko eine kleinstadt in der
provinz hunan
es ist oktober 2012 die spuren des
goldenen rises führen uns an diese
schule denn hier haben us-forscher
goldenen reis an sechs- bis achtjährigen
kindern getestet
laut kritischen gentech wissenschaftlern
und greenpeace ohne die eltern
aufzuklären dass es sich um gentech reis
handelt wir sind hier weil wir
herausfinden wollen was wirklich
passiert ist
es gelingt uns mit betroffenen schülern
und ihren familien ins gespräch zu
kommen und sie zum versuch zu befragen
die us forscher gaben die schul
mittagessen gratis ab den eltern aber
verschwiegen sie dass sie an ihren
kindern ging der ich reiße testeten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die menschen fühlen sich hintergangen
was nur haben sich die verantwortlichen
dabei gedacht die studie finanziert hat
das staatliche gesundheitsamt der
vereinigten staaten durchgeführt hat
sich die amerikanische tufts university
sie nimmt inhaltlich keine stellung das
forschungsprojekt sei gegenstand an der
laufenden untersuchung wie aber passt
diese geschichte zur humanitären idee
des erfinders wir sind davon ausgegangen
dass alles korrekt gelaufen ist und ich
bin weiterhin weil ich kenne ich die
chinesischen partner aber ich kenne die
die partner ausschau
ich traue denen eigentlich zu dass das
korrekt gemacht haben
warum müssen sie das denn wissen wie
wurde der spinat produziert dem versuch
verwendet wurde und wie die gelatine
die sind denn beta karotin kapseln hatte
woher kam das öl
es gibt keinen hinweis dass von der
gentechnologie irgendein problem ausgeht
unbedenkliche gentechnologie an pflanzen
an ratten versuch jedoch wirft fragen
auf
an der französischen universität kam
wurden raten über zwei jahre mit gentech
mais gefüttert der erste langzeitversuch
mit genmanipulierten futtermitteln
überhaupt resultat der gentech mais
verursachte tumore geleitet hat diese
studie der französische genentech
forscher will eric serra linie die
tumore kamen schon nach dem vierten
monat
sie wissen ein tumor erscheint
frühestens ab 90 tagen
sie sind explodiert in der anzahl wie
auch die krankheiten an ihre und leber
die zum tod der raten führten bereits am
ende des ersten jahres
das heißt schon nach der hälfte eines
normalen lebens dieser tiere sie release
interpretation der tumorbildung die
gegen manipulation habe die chemische
zusammensetzung des futtermais verändert
und das könnte die abwehrmechanismen der
tiere gegen krebs reduziert haben
unsere resultate zeigen dass gentech
produkte die bereits im verkehr sind
gestoppt werden müssten
diese studie hat unter wissenschaftlern
sehr kontroverse reaktionen ausgelöst
die gentech forschung ist ideologisch
und politisch hoch aufgeladen ihrer
linie fordert eine genauere abklärung
der risiken auch beim goldpreis
wenn man seriös ist und mit der
gesundheit der öffentlichkeit nicht
spielt muss man zwingend solche
langzeitversuche machen bevor man diesen
reise in verkehr bringt für den
schweizer markt erhielte der goldene
reis eine zulassung kaum ohne
tierversuche schreibt das bundesamt für
gesundheit für die zulassung auf den
philippinen aber fehlen solche versuche
sie haben die studie des schweizer
nationalfonds über die schweiz indirekt
klar steht dass es keinerlei gefährdung
von allem was bisher bekannt ist
jemanden das auch von der theorie her
keine gehirn zu erwarten ist
im golden rice haben wir die substanz
die wir mit den karotten täglich essen
von dem wir schon hunderte von kilos
gegessen haben
ohne langzeitstudien ob das eigene
tätigen wirkung hat ist genau diese
moleküle wissenschaftlich eindeutig
nachgewiesen
und jetzt sollen wir mit dem golden rice
der kinder der voll retten kanzler
blinden haben zu sterben
die heute 50 jahre langzeitstudien
machen wie vor wir akzeptieren dass in
diesen preis essen darf das ist schon
ein bisschen gesponnen
haben gentechpflanzen doch unbekannte
nebenwirkungen soll man sich wirklich
auf sie einlassen
die insel bohol eine provinz im
mittleren teil der philippinen will das
risiko nicht eingehen
die inselregierung hat gentechpflanzen
verboten ihr also kein gold race in
zukunft aber gerade auf boron sollen die
leute laut nationaler statistik stark an
vitamin a mangel leiden wie lösen die
leute dieses problem es ist
sonntagmorgen
wir sind zu besuch bei familie omark
einer typischen preis bauernfamilie
reis kochen gehört zu einer der ersten
handlungen am tag
die familie lebt von der
selbstversorgung
sie hat kaum möglichkeiten geld zu
verdienen sich nahrungsmittel im laden
zu kaufen
sie ist angewiesen auf das was ihr die
natur schenkt durch der rachael bricht
einige zweige formal umgebung ab seine
blätter sind besonders reich an
vitaminen und spurenelementen auch an
provitamin a und für den geschmack ein
paar heim mit zitronengras
[Musik]
er ist gibt es roten reiss sei
gehaltvoller als der weiße erfahren wir
dazu etwas fisch und als beilage das
ballon bei gemüse aus dem garten leben
preis gibt es immer und dazu je nachdem
was es im garten hat und was wir uns
leisten können
in bremer fleisch ist selten ab und zu
ein ei das eben was die bescheidene
landwirtschaft her gibt wichtige
nährstoffe lieferanten sind früchte
kokosnuss mango banane
wir sind überrascht wie viel die familie
aus dem wenigen das sie hat herausholt
baumarkt zeigt uns seine reisfelder
er besitzt lediglich eine viertel hektar
land meist reicht der reis nicht einmal
für die versorgung seiner sechsköpfigen
familie jetzt in diesem stadium musste
den preis alle zwei tage fluten so kann
er den haupt schädling eine schnecke
biologisch regulieren zwar wenig aber
das ohne chemie mit dieser devise
seit der kleinbauer gut gefahren
bestätigt er uns wir erfahren dass die
bauernfamilien ob diese insel in
sogenannten two rocks
zusammengeschlossen sind in einheiten
von zehn bis fünfzehn haushalten werden
sie in landwirtschafts fragen geschult
nötig bekommen sie sogar pflanzen setzen
ihr gratis
daneben bildet die inselregierung lokale
gesundheits arbeiterinnen aus in solchen
kursen lernen sie beispielsweise welche
gemüse und früchte reich an vitamin a
sind wir besitzen die gelegenheit und
fragen ob es auf der insel aktuelle
fälle von vitamin a mangel gebe es gibt
kein erfassten fälle nicht in der 90
wann war denn der letzte fall der letzte
fall den ich gesehen habe war ein kind
im jahre 1986
diese aussage erstaunt laut nationaler
statistik gilt die insel als vitamin a
mangel gebiet die lokalen gesundheits
arbeiterinnen aber stellen keinen mangel
fest ihnen ist nicht bekannt wo und wie
die nationalen daten erhoben werden
der besuch auf der insel wirft neue
fragen auf
wir treffen auf eine bevölkerung geht es
warm ist sich aber ausgewogen ernährt
entgegen den offiziellen nationalen
statistiken weist hier nichts auf einen
vitamin a mangel hin
[Musik]
was sagt der goldpreis erfinder zu
unseren beobachtungen
das ist für mich nicht überraschend denn
das ist nicht sehr einfach zu
dokumentieren
obwohl statistisch völlig sicher ist
dass diese fälle existieren philippinen
ist kein sehr günstiges land dafür den
philippinen ist vitamin a mangel noch
ein problem für etwa zehn prozent
übervölkerung anderen ländern haben sie
bessere aussichten ich war vor kurzem in
indien
ich war für nicht einmal eine halbe
stunde in einem dorf einer
traditionellen landbevölkerung und harry
zwei solche fälle gesehen also diese
fälle existieren schon man muss nur in
der richtigen bevölkerungsschichten
maßnahmen obwohl der vitamin a mangel in
indien höher sein soll ist die
einführung des wunder rises zuerst auf
den philippinen geplant
hier haben wir unzählige organisationen
und stellen kontaktiert um die vitamin a
unterversorgung zu dokumentieren
ohne erfolg
gerne hätten wir die nationalen behörden
darauf angesprochen auch ohne erfolg
stattdessen schicken sie uns ein mail
und verweisen uns an eine andere stelle
wieder einmal wunder die uns man schickt
uns dorthin wo wir schon mal angeklopft
haben ans nationale
reisforschungsinstitut films
an die stelle die zusammen mit ihr den
golden rice so schnell wie möglich auf
den markt bringen will
und plötzlich ging hier die tore auf wir
haben einen termin mit antonio
[Musik]
antonio alfonso ist die nummer eins des
goldpreis projektes wir wollen wissen
weshalb wir die goldpreis ernte nicht
filmen durften ja wir erhielten ihre
anfrage und unser kommunikationsteam hat
sie geprüft wir haben tatsächlich
begonnen bei der aufsichtsbehörde eine
bewilligung einzuholen und am ende hat
das projekt entschieden dass es jetzt
nicht gut wäre
aus welchen gründen das kann ich ihnen
nicht sagen
wir sind aber trotzdem zu gold in einem
raise gekommen
woher haben sie das ich bin sicher der
kommt nicht von den philippinen
ist das wirklich guten preis ich glaube
es nicht weil es keinen weg für jemanden
wie sie von den medien gibt zu solchem
reis zu kommen
in den philippinen gilt die politik dass
nur ausgewählte leute zugang zum golden
rice haben und ich glaube nicht dass sie
dazugehören
und was passiert jetzt mit dem
geernteten was sind ihre nächsten
schritte
die nächsten schritte sind wir stellen
die daten von den feldversuchen zusammen
auch die aus dem labor wie protein und
zusammensetzung analysen
dann stellen wir diese daten der
genehmigungsbehörde dem land
wirtschaftsdebatte mend zur verfügung
sie machen dann eine evaluation ist
golden rice sicher erfüllt golden rice
die bio sicherheitsanforderungen
wann wird die philippinische bevölkerung
goldene reis essen wann golden rice für
den konsum
möglich sein wird ich wünschte ich
könnte es ihnen sagen es hängt davon ab
ob und wann die behörde die genehmigung
erteilt aufgrund der daten die wir zur
verfügung stellen wenn es nach ihnen
ginge würde die philippinische
bevölkerung nie gold und den reis essen
die reist zuchtstation der kleinbauern
organisation massiver eine nationale gut
vernetzte vereinigung die 35.000
mitglieder zählt diese bauern pflegen
die felder mit traditionellen geräten
und setzen auf traditionelle reissorten
hier auf diesen feldern haben wir
zurzeit 1200 sorten gepflanzt
mit den sorten die nur in der nassen
saison angepflanzt werden können haben
wir insgesamt eine auswahl von 2.600
reissorten eine enorme sortenvielfalt
medina und seine leute erfassen jeder
einzelne mit all ihren eigenschaften
bauern können sich hier mit bewährtem
traditionell im saatgut eindecken und es
eigenständig weiter vermehren kostenlos
guido medina führt uns zum schatz der
organisation
das ist eine ausstellung unserer sorten
hier haben wir die traditionellen und
hier die masse packs orten
sie alle sind wichtig und müssen
erhalten bleiben
viele sind an unterschiedliche
umweltbedingungen angepasst wie an die
klimaerwärmung und andere extreme
ereignisse um zu überleben und etwas zu
essen zu haben sind die bauen auf diese
vielfalt der sorten angewiesen
in der region dazu kommt gerade in
zeiten in denen das saatgut oft
patentiert ist und von den bauern
gekauft werden muss ist es für
kleinbauern wichtig das saatgut in den
eigenen händen haben zum überleben zu
überleben brauche es golden rice licht
der sorten spezialistin uns unbedingt
noch in den reis aus der eigenen
kollektion zum probieren geben
das ist schwarzer reis gemäss forschern
enthält der schwarze als viel
betacarotin oder provitamin a und diese
sorte wächst hier ganz natürlich die
wächst natürlich die bauen pflanzen sie
selber
wer in diesem land will den goldenen
wunder reichs die regierung die forscher
das internationale
reisforschungsinstitut irri auch dass
ihre öffnet und schließlich doch noch
die türen die kehrtwende bleibt
schleierhaft
[Musik]
man verspricht uns sogar richtige golden
rice pflanzen auf philippinische boden
zu zeigen zwar nicht draußen auf dem
feld die ursprünglich einmal abgemacht
aber immerhin schwer bewacht auf dem
versuchsgelände im hauptquartier
rust argentino führt uns zum
bestgehüteten schatz des erie der zugang
zu diesem gewächshaus es kontrolliert
man muss sich eintragen und wir stellen
sicher dass keine tiere vögel oder
ratten in dieses gewächshaus reinkommen
und das saatgut verstreuen
wir wollen sicherstellen dass die ganze
forschung nach allen regeln der kunst
abläuft hermetisch abgeriegelt ist der
wunde riss hermetisch abgeriegelt auch
zum schutz der tiere
was passiert wenn vögel plötzlich diese
beta carotin körner picken
eine frage die bis heute nicht
untersucht wurde demonstriert wie die
gentech pflanzen stück für stück
geerntet werden
wir testen eine ganze reihe an
verschiedenen sorten und schauen welche
den höchsten gehalt an beta carotin hat
wir versuchen die sorte bei jedem
schritt zu verbessern
das sind jetzt pflanzen die gegenüber
denjenigen draußen im feld verbessert
worden sind wir sind also immer noch
dran den beta carotin gehalt zu steigern
bis er einen gewissen richtwert erreicht
hat der reis ist offenbar immer noch in
der testphase
dennoch sollen die behörde noch dieses
jahr für eine marktzulassung prüfen
wieder einmal wundern wir uns die
behörde hat bisher bereits mehrere
gentechpflanzen bewilligt ein magischer
moment erst ohne schale kommt der gelbe
kern zum vorschein
bei diesem anblick scheinen die
verantwortlichen überzeugt wird der
siegeszug ihre körner schon bald
beginnen
die hälfte der menschheit ist jeden tag
kreis wenn du reist mit vitamin a
anreichert kannst du vielen leuten
helfen ohne zusätzliche kosten
wir hoffen dass der reis schon dieses
jahr erhältlich sein wird
ich wäre nicht überrascht wenn leute in
50 jahren sagen weißer reis was ist das
für ein armenisches zeug und ihre
großväter sagen das haben wir mal
gegessen und die leute können das kaum
glauben
zuerst soll der goldene reis nur auf den
philippinen und in bangladesch auf den
markt kommen
[Musik]
das weh die gates von der ist so
sie bestimmt weil sie das geld gibt der
portikus aber will eine weltweite
verbreitung seines wunder rises und zwar
so schnell wie möglich er ärgert sich
über das diktat des geldes sind
eingestiegen am ende also es war jetzt
fast fertig waren
wir haben 20 jahre entwicklungsarbeit
sind ohne jede unterstützung von der
gates foundation und am ende kommt bald
geht's mit seinem reichtum und und
kassiert das projekt und machte ein
großprojekt 1000 syngenta hat das
forschungsmaterial an ihre weitergegeben
und später in absprache mit der gates
foundation auch verantwortung und rechte
am golden rice an ihre übertragen
mit dieser vereinbarung im jahre 2010
waren dessen erfinder nicht
einverstanden
doch ihr einspruch war chancenlos der
portikus fühlt sich heute ausgebootet
der reis mit dem heute in den
philippinen gearbeitet wird der gehört
eigentlich gar nicht mehr ihnen gehört
uns moralisch und rechtlich aber
aufgrund des material transfer agreement
ist es eine vereinbarung in der wir
umgangen worden sind zwischen der geht's
von tischen und ihren und syngenta
das heißt wir haben im augenblick keinen
direkten einfluss auf das was in den
letzten zwei jahren amiri passiert wir
sind nicht glücklich über diese
entwicklung halten die für nicht nur
unfair sondern auch juristisch nicht
korrekt aber wir werden deswegen kein
recht zeiten sind anfangen syngenta
schreibt uns die darstellung dass sie
eine gewisse zeit bestimmen kann was mit
dem golden rice passiert ist falsch und
weiter wir möchten festhalten dass unser
interesse an golden rice rein
humanitärer natur ist ein edles motiv
das in gent aber nicht selbst vor der
kamera vertreten will wieder wundern uns
denn während wochen haben wir versucht
syngenta für eine kooperation an diesem
film zu gewinnen ohne erfolg
und der enttäuschte golden rice erfinder
porträt kuss er hofft immer noch am ziel
bin ich wenn dieser reis von den
menschen gegessen wird für die er
gemacht worden ist das heißt die armen
in entwicklungsländern die in großer
gefahr sind vitamin a mangel ernste
medizinische konsequenzen zu haben
ich bin inzwischen 79 weiß nicht ob ich
noch ein jahr länger als zwei oder drei
ich hoffe ich werde noch am leben sein
wenn endlich der goldene reis in
philippinen vielleicht bangladesch -
bringt der gentechniker ist von ingo
potrykus den menschen in
entwicklungsländern tatsächlich das was
sich die erfinder erhofft deshalb
versteckt sich die behörde hinter
verschlossenen türen wird der goldene
reis auf den philippinen zugelassen
bedeutet das einen dammbruch mit
weltweiter ausstrahlung ist das
wichtigste grundnahrungsmittel für die
menschheit gentechnisch verändert auf
dem markt stehen viele weiteren gegen
lebensmitteln tür und tor offen